welcome to the 2020 edition of
shocktober
where we celebrate the month of october
by talking about some of
the more mysterious and darker aspects
of the world's religious traditions
and when it comes to the region of
arabia and the middle east there is
perhaps no
more famous creature or monster
than the jinn of course and we
will or have already dedicated a whole
other video specifically to the gin
depending on
how i choose to release these videos
but in this video we're going to be
looking at some of the
lesser known characters in the folklore
of
arabia
[Music]
one good thing to keep in mind about
this subject
is that before the arrival of islam
the arabs were a people who didn't
really write
very much in terms of written material
so
when we talk about the mythology of
ancient arabia
we are mostly relying on later sources
often medieval sources or even later
than that
and and the primary of these sources is
actually the
stories of the arabian nights or more
properly called the thousand and one
nights since a lot of the stories
originate from regions outside of arabia
there are a lot of persian stories
a lot of indian stories and so on i also
say
creatures of arabia and mythology of
arabia but
when it comes to a lot of these myths
they are often shared with a lot of
other neighboring cultures and sort of
cross over between
cultural boundaries so to say and
myths like this are rarely exclusive as
we will also
see there are also sources about this
from medieval zoological or
philosophical treatises
that gives us enough information at
least that we know a
fair amount about some of the mythology
that existed in the region of arabia
number one the
there are plenty of stories about giant
bird-like creatures
in many cultures and arabia is no
different
we find two recurring birds in fact the
roh and the anka the roch is a giant
bird of prey that is so large that it is
said to be able to grab
entire elephants with its feet
it is thought to live in or come from
the island of madagascar
and features in several stories and
accounts
the most famous account of the roch
comes from the arabian nights and the
story of sinbad the sailor
which in itself is one of the most
famous stories in that collection
simbad actually runs into the rook on
two occasions on his
second and his fifth voyage and the
first time
sinbad is stranded on a desert island
desperate to escape to come back to
civilization
when he suddenly finds an enormous bird
egg and as he's inspecting this egg the
sky
suddenly turns black or dark because the
mother rooh
suddenly appears now as the rook is
later
sleeping sinbad ties his turban
to the feet or the leg of the rooh
which then in the morning flies off to
distant lands where
simbad can can sort of untie himself and
quickly hide behind a rock so he escapes
the rook this time and it flies
back home but not before grabbing a
giant serpent with its feet to feed on
the second time sinbad encounters the
roc does not go as well
this time the sailor and his crew find
another
egg on an island and despite simbad's
warnings they crack
open the egg and eat the chick inside
obviously not the greatest idea as the
two parent rooks then appear
and enact the revenge by basically
destroying their boats and killing the
entire crew
except for simbad himself who narrowly
escapes
outside the arabian night we have other
accounts as well
for example from the famous actual
person and and traveler ibn batuta
he describes how he once saw what he
thought was a
flying mountain over the china seas
before of course realizing that it was
in fact a
rooh bird rule of thumb if a creature
can be mistaken for a mountain
it's generally pretty big similar to the
roch the
anka is said to be a beautiful large
usually female bird that can be found
very poetically at quote the place of
the setting sun
it is sometimes depicted as a phoenix a
griffin an eagle or sphinx
and just like the jinn the anka is
thought to originate on the mythical
mount
cough which lies at the end of the world
or the edge of the world
and is a creature that is often used to
symbolize the purest of spirits
in fact in the writings of the mystic
even arabi the anka
is described as quote the dust cloud
within which god
opens up the forms of the universe
so you can see that the anka is often
used in a symbolic fashion to describe
mystical or metaphysical ideas
whereas the roch is often presented as
an intimidating and dangerous creature
the anka is usually benevolent and
represents things like
purity nobility and beauty
as already stated these birds of course
remind us
of other giant birds in in
in mythologies and cultures around the
world in particular there is of course a
very strong connection here with the
seymour of persian mythology who often
functions in a very similar way and
has become a very important symbol in
sufism in particular
much thanks to the poet farido di natas
masterpiece the conference of the birds
similarly the anka which i have just
described is used by ibn arabi
in his in a treatise he wrote called the
itahadar koni
which he describes meeting four
different birds
sitting in the tree of creation or the
tree of existence at the center of
creation
as he is having one of his mystical
experiences and one of these birds
is indeed the anka number two
the bahamut the bahamut is a legendary
giant
fish or whale there is something about
mythology and very
large things the bahamut is an
unfathomably large creature much larger
than anything that has ever lived on
this earth as far as we know
it is so large in fact that it is said
to be the very
foundation upon which the world stands
in arabic sources like in zechariah
or the wonders of creation the earth
is described as resting on the back of a
giant
bull which in turn stands on
the bahamut which then obviously is even
larger
than this bull this big fish or whale
itself is then supported by the
shoulders of an
angel this enormous whale is of course
fascinating enough in itself
but it is also clearly very similar both
in form and
definitely in name to the hebrew
behemoth
that is mentioned in the hebrew bible or
old testament
it features in one of my favorite books
of the bible the book of job and is
usually considered a giant
chaos monster that existed at the
beginning of creation
and was defeated by god in like some
kind of battle
no real physical description is given of
this beast other than its very large
size but it is unmistakable that the
word bahamut in arabic
strongly relates to the hebrew behemoth
and that we are likely dealing with a
cross-culture myth
here this shows us how interconnected
the cultures and mythologies of the
ancient world could be
a lot of the time number three nasnas
perhaps the most monstrous and gross
creature that we'll talk about today
is called the nasnas it also features in
the arabian nights and in one of the
more
obscure stories from the collection
called the story of the sage and the
scholar
the nasnas are here and otherwise a kind
of zombie-like creature that is
half man both literally and figuratively
in a figurative sense it is thought that
nasnas is the
unholy offspring of of the union of a
human being
and a shack which is a kind of jinn or
evil
demon-like creature and in a literal
sense
as a result of this unholy union the
the the nas nas are literally half a
human being so
only has half of the head it's like the
head is the body is cut off
uh in the middle the sword has one half
of a head it has
one arm and only one leg but
don't let that fool you because
apparently they can jump and move at
terrifying speeds despite their
only having one leg and if one of them
catches up to you
that's very bad news because according
to some stories a single touch from a
nas means
instant death truly the staff of
nightmares the nasnos are seen by some
as a kind of jinn while others consider
them unique creatures of their own
why would someone ever think to come up
with such a terrifying creature you ask
i i wish i knew number four dun dun
returning to the world of very large
animals the so-called dun dun
is another giant fish or whale
while not as enormous as the previously
mentioned bahamut the dundan is still
large enough that it apparently can
swallow an entire
ship in a single gulp which is still
pretty impressive if you ask me
it is most famously mentioned again in
the arabian nights where
it is described by a merman as the quote
largest
fish in the sea you can help but think
about other similar legends and myths
even today there are documentaries
dedicated to discussing whether the
megalodon which was a giant shark that
lived a few million years ago
is still lurking in the deep ocean there
seems to be
this tendency by human beings to imagine
what may lie hidden in the undiscovered
depths of the sea
i mean it is sometimes said that we know
more about outer space than we do about
our own oceans
so who knows after all speaking of
merman and giant fish
there is another related monster that
pops up in medieval arabic and muslim
texts
who is known as literally translating to
the physician
of the sea it is described by the very
famous early muslim
alchemist and philosopher jabed ibn
haiyan or
gebber in that nice form and is
described as a fish-like being of
incredible knowledge
and power the tagpipe can transform into
a mermaid and carries a large jewel
on its head which can be used to heal
any injuries by simply touching it
the bach in the name may literally refer
to the sea
as the creature's home or it could refer
to its
immense knowledge like having knowledge
as vast as the sea or
it's perhaps a reference to both of
these in a rather strange account jabet
ibn haiyan is said to have actually
captured one of these creatures while on
a sea voyage
one of the crew men later fell in love
with it in its beautiful mermaid form
and they had a child before the tahabib
eventually escaped back into the ocean
the tabi balbach is generally thought to
be a benevolent creature
so not dangerous and nothing to be
feared but still
anything that hides in the ocean is kind
of terrifying to me
number five falak that last part
certainly can't be said for our last
creature today which is known as the
falak
the phalaq is surprise surprise a giant
serpent so if you have a fear of snakes
you should probably bail at this point
like the bahamut the falak is one of
those just unreasonably large
creatures if you've seen the harry
potter movies and you're thinking about
that
basilisk think again the falak
completely dwarfs it by comparison this
serpent
is said to reside in the seventh deepest
level
of hell it is so large that it can
swallow the whole world and
the only thing that keeps it from doing
so is its immense fear of god
when we look at the different
mythologies and legends of the world's
cultures
the snake or serpent is one of the most
recurring
and common symbols and features from the
quetzalcoatl of the aztecs and native
central americans
to the snake of midgard and norse
mythology that surrounds the earth
the serpent in the garden of eden that
tempts adam and eve and
also of course now the phalec of the
middle eastern folklore
there's clearly something about snakes
perhaps they somehow represent one of
the most dangerous and intimidating
animals that exist in our world
and their recurrence is a result of our
natural fear of them
who knows but they are certainly very
fascinating
so those are some of the most famous and
recurring creatures
that we find in the folklore of arabia
and the middle east generally the most
famous of them all which i haven't
talked about in this video is of course
the
gin and they are so famous and an
important in fact that i will
be dedicating a whole other separate
video just
to the gin which will have already come
out or will
come out next week depending on how i
choose to structure
the or release these videos so look
forward to or
i hope you liked the video on the gin
as always i would like to thank my
patrons without whom none of this would
be possible
it is thanks to you that i can keep
making these videos with this
level of quality and quantity and of
course just inspires me to
make more videos if any of
the other people out there would like to
become patrons there will be of course
highly appreciated i will leave a link
to my patreon page in the description
if not then you can always of course
like the video subscribe to the channel
if you aren't already
and leave a comment so we can continue
this discussion and let me know what you
thought of this video
i'll see you next time
you